listen I'm the most moldable yeah though
one thing I don't want to do is say
something I don't believe it cuz that
will undermine everything I got
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You this was last Monday morning
in her life
[Applause]
strategy insights data and creative
teams and that and that pays that house
and pays for all the creative output so
you know it's interesting there's
actually two people that I'm thinking
about right now that I'm about to
allocate to something else
probably Saudi rock you know extremely
stressed today got real yes you are
you've already been antsy now you're
asking me to make this film mad don't
you think that he's super stressed now
he looks good well he looks good looking
good investment you're worried that
we're not gonna be able to make a really
strong I was so glad all these are
bombing planning the apps and they're
not letting you do a little bang all you
got is when you doing my makeup right
yep and make Natalina running around and
organizing yep and so you're worried
admit that you're worried about today
I'm a little I knew it I know you
[Music]
I tell them this
but giving away some of the 60-second
Club giveaways so we're about to give
Marshall Paul live three minutes of my
time I saw they saw it it's my favorite
snapchat feature right here yo you there
is there all right there we go yo you
are very live with Gary B how are you
good man what's going on with you no
problem I love that man thank you so
much so we got 180 seconds what's like
the best thing I can give you help you
if you were going back to the very
beginning and you were starting out
nothing like I am don't money right
momentum you always talk about keeping
the moment I'm going keep momentum going
when when you're in a hole and that
momentum seems to stop how can I keep
the momentum going in my life in my
business so is it your when times are
tough you're getting to a place where
it's uh it's just hard to like
quote-unquote get up in the morning like
just trying to break through the
adversity that is naturally always there
always gonna be there to some point I
don't usually have problems with that
it's just like today for example you
know I I gotta shut up last night I get
this three-minute conversation with you
and this is a perfect example of when
momentum is really rocking and rolling
yep pop uh how can I capitalize on that
and continue demo Menem when that
momentum is ready to stop how do you
firstly keep by recognizing how
insignificant and significant these
things are so this three minutes
together is amazing and it's awesome and
you know you won this you know time and
you hustled for it but you know this
three minutes with
you and I is not going to be the reason
that you're successful in business it's
a it's a nice to have I think too many
people over ask people always think like
okay now that this happened this is the
reason I'm going to blow up how old are
you good nothing good is going to happen
for the next ten years then your that
but honestly if you actually believe
that versus just saying that to me
because you know I care about that then
you don't need anything else for me do
you understand that's it man like like
when it's when it's when you're down
realize how amazing it is and when
you're up realize how not great it's
going to be right like like it's it's
pushing the opposite direction of what
it looks like actually is happening got
it yep yep no I don't want any old
quarterback as much as I have no idea
Bryce Petty's gonna work out I have no
interest in Romo I have no interest in
Kaepernick I have no interest in Cutler
I want to go young I want to be crapped
in five years rebuild and then make a
run patience thank you thanks brother
take care bye bye awesome access that's
access is it right like that's so
amazing first of all that's a triple win
because he's pumped we just create a
good content like that I don't know if I
remember saying when it's one way push
the other way that's what I actually do
that's balanced never let when it's too
high go low when it's low go high and he
wins and now the community is going to
want more access the whole thing's
freaking great
[Music]
this I'm the most moldable yet though
one thing I don't want to do is say
something I don't believe it because
that will undermine everything I got
[Music]
[Music]
happy new rock
[Music]
yo my man Oh
[Music]
see my man let's leave that wait to see
you I think I'm good here really great
job looking pretty all right [ __ ] you
swipe up swipe up swipe up what's crazy
is this quote came because he's filming
me all day we make a show and then we
pull the amount of smart and creative
[ __ ] that must be coming out of your
dome like just knowing you from afar
magic but it just lost in history I
don't know you looking for if I told you
Nia the celebrity looking going to five
targets and trying to find a Christmas
tree because you know you don't even
understand like the thing that people
don't understand is people can sit and
make fun of the Kardashians or dj khaled
things like that there's so much it all
goes back to reality TV people are just
intrigued you know what's even better
than TV though we edit what people yeah
you sign with Discovery Channel or you
started you sign with MTV or you sign
with Fox you don't get to say they'll
put you in the paper that's right when
you have your d-roc and one other person
you're sitting there and at the end and
you're watching for 20 minutes be like
oh [ __ ] no no I said that thing like I
can't let Karen know that like I do it
all day I ever watch any of my own [ __ ]
now I have to because there might be
some little subtle thing I say that I
know that employee if they watch it
would know that means they're getting
fired I gotta kill it anyway so I kind
of have this concern about giving away
something that games over by the way I
just feel like that games over like to
let them hear
Boyd's comes complete you know what I
would give by the way by the way I
respect that and by the way that's your
art I don't want to tell you what to do
but here's what I would tell you I
assume tell me if I'm wrong I'm just
making some assumptions you're always
debating several like songs don't make
the cut so one of the things I think and
you also probably know like when I saw
when the songs that you know you know
when the songs 90% you're like this song
is definitely gonna make it I'm just got
to fix it up a little you probably know
when songs are at 10% and it may not
make it you could be smart about what
you share in don't chair you know if
you're like how this is fifty-fifth like
one thing actually those are bad
examples 5050 you're [ __ ] with it you
know like that would be cool because you
would [ __ ] with it people would see it
and then you'd read the comments and be
like okay like I actually think I don't
think look there's that classic thing
where the guy that invented the porch
said if I listen to my audience I would
have just made a faster Toyota or some
[ __ ] I don't remember exactly what he
said so I don't think your audience
should be making your music that's why
you were you I do think though that once
in a while the feedback isn't too bad
and you could pick up some nuances yeah
baby she don't stay in the same it's the
way it should be right like you know but
when you have cat here's what you've got
you have talent it doesn't take as much
you know like same with me as an
entrepreneur like I'm actually a good
business man not just saying it on
Instagram you know so once you deploy
the talent to the right place where
people paying attention it explodes so
you're in a big big big advantage it's
just time for you to reframe the way you
think about the world it's just real and
you're gonna be like you're gonna be in
a relationship with your fans go figure
go figure
got it and the best part I'll be real
frank with you man you're a good dude
like I've been really kind of doing my
homework a little bit since we met I was
like damn you know like you're gonna win
big you're just likeable you're just
real likeable and that [ __ ] matters or
is it first you're just good that's why
that's why you're gonna win that that's
why I didn't curse a hundred mine too
but guess what those are the best things
cool
Chakri 2ct rising yeah always
yeah man you guys to let me know how I
can help I'll wait for you to hit me up
you guys ponder feel what's right you
know baby cool alright guys take care
happy holidays
Thank You people thank you d rockefeller
he was a good dude
whether you're a super famous artist or
Joe Schmo like me telling your story
consistently and authentically in the
places where people take pay attention
it's the game hey hey what's up what's
up what's up dude things are good man
I'm glad we really make this happen
sorry I'm a little late so you're here
right that's right that's why I ask you
you live here
how'd the meeting go with the team very
well good I like you too you assured me
that you're like the poof of cloud now
they were amazing I love them
had a great time super bright very
personable good and they're and they're
built to know what our issues are which
is time yes it's the only thing that
matters so true so what you know and
this time we have together is there you
know I hope they gave you the energy of
what I want what I want everybody know
which is it's weird
I'm you're gonna what I'm about to say
you're gonna find funny I don't like
selling I don't find that funny i watch
enough of your content know that yeah so
like I don't love be to be like you know
Under Armour and chase and Budweiser I
hate this so much you can't like selling
a person on a service is even worse but
what I will say is I'm proud that you
know you knowing my narrative everybody
wanted this seven years ago and I went
and sold chase and Pepsi because I knew
I could bring them value for what they
paid me it took me and I only unlocked
it you probably saw the deck where my
numbers exploded
only in the last year have I really
really figured out how to make this
worthwhile to you to neo who just like
you know I figured it out we got it so
now it's not scary right it's not all of
that value is the only thing that's
sustainable so it has only many things
that's sustainable like if your app like
but I think CES is the right time all
right that's good great to see you
together my Chitti MA so delicious
thank you yeah absolutely take it back
Tyler I gotta go hey Andrea just about
to go on a conference call um great day
films in TV hung in LA hung out with
some Vayner talent meetings living the
dream going to work out now see you
later
[Music]